who's ready for a story
all right
once upon a time
in a land
very very close to us
there was a planet
and that planet was on fire
but it didn't start that way
global atmospheric carbon dioxide
concentrations in parts per million for
the past 800 thousand years didn't
exceed 300 parts per million and that
peak happened about 300 000 years ago
the annual rate of increase of
atmospheric carbon dioxide is measured
in parts
oh
looks like you've fallen asleep
climate change is the most
urgent issue facing humanity today but
telling it like a boring story like i
just did is not going to create the
change we need to secure livable future
we need climate activism to be
mainstream
we need the fight against climate change
to be cool let's try something different
ladies and gentlemen please welcome my
verse and chris and warren
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dear children hope you listen this is
mother earth from beyond your birth i've
been here when the sun emerged i fed you
from me for no love returned to see you
grow up and be underserved in other
words let me nurture don't let him
deceive you self-sufficient cause you
get it from me that light build from the
sun paid definitely don't let them
hustle you your power cause they're
energy free i gave mountains to guide
you and rivers to ride through trees to
help you breathe but don't seem to be
mindful the other creatures need you
cause they live here beside you a
mother's nation make sure that you fit
for survival like finish your greens eat
less than your eyes do take the trash
out we discipline and recycle season's
getting heated scolding y'all will be
frightful you gonna learn to clean your
room when you live under my roof
stop waiting for a sign
please ease your mother's mind in eden
we could be take care of you and me
while water swell and rise please ease
your mother dear mother earth where do
we begin
to change all this mess left for us to
fix we made aesthetics be the reason
that this threat exists they want our
votes to address it till elections end
cause politicians in these businesses
are best of friends some costs are up
profits but at what expense
accountability is knowing this affects
our kids it made me realize that my part
in this is just as big too much
convenience kept polluting up our human
nature minor changes can be mega for our
futures favor reduce waste reuse plates
i mean actually try with better habits
they can't guess is if we travel on
bikes to my family going green trying to
lead the effort of less carbon
footprints be the cleanest steppers
ain't no favorites climate change it
could reach whoever cause it don't
matter what class we still breathe
together
bless creatures fall and die wild by
your sin their eyes stop waiting for a
sign
please ease your mother's mind in eating
we could be
take care of you with me
while water swelling rise please ease
your shame on the same truth please read
this letter same scar same water we
drink together same soil same fruit we
eat together it don't matter what class
we still breed together
[Applause]
how do you
create a movement
how do you raise the masses
how do you get people behind an idea to
inspire action
you make it mainstream
in 1993
snoop dogg released his song gin and
juice produced by dr dre
some people know it here
it peaked at number eight on billboard's
hot 100 chart in the united states and
it was nominated for a 1994 grammy award
for best rap solo performance
the lyrics famously go
sippin on gin and juice laid back with
my mind on my money and my money on my
mind
in the song snoop references a brand of
gin called seagrams and the success of
the song gin and juice led to a roughly
20 percent increase in segregation sales
now you may be thinking all right samir
i see the point you're trying to make
but using hip hop to sell alcohol is
easy
climate change is a little bit more
complex
fair enough
but there are examples of how hip-hop
artists have leveraged their cultural
capital to influence society's views on
and engagement with incredibly serious
topics take mental health for example
in the 1970s
one of the early hip-hop groups called
grandmaster flash and furious 5
rapt about the day-to-day inequities and
injustices faced by black communities in
the united states and how this impacted
their mental health
one of their songs called the message
was the seventh rap song to ever be on
any billboard hot 100 chart and new york
times named it as the most popular pop
single of 1982. sorry the most powerful
pop single of 1982
and then in the 80s and 90s mental
health issues started to become more
mainstream in hip-hop lyrics in 1991
in their classic song mind playing
tricks on me
hip-hop group ghetto boys captured the
realities of post-traumatic stress
within urban communities
one of the three members of the group
named scarface wrote most of the song
you see he was diagnosed with bipolar
disorder at a young age and the lyrics
of the song describe the mental anguish
and exhaustion for life of minorities in
america dealing with symptoms of
post-traumatic stress disorder
loneliness suicidal ideation and
paranoia
and then in 2017 hip-hop artist logic
released his song
1-800-273-8255
that's the phone number for the national
suicide prevention lifeline
the week before the song was released
logic tweeted
i made this song for all of you who are
in a dark place and can't seem to find
the light
the director of the national suicide
prevention lifeline said that on the day
the song was released
they had the second highest call volume
in the history of their service
and after logic performed the song on
mtv's video music awards later that year
they reported a 50 increase in call
volume
you can see that while
talking about the problem to raise
awareness is important
it's not until logic started rapping
about a solution that things really
started changing
and that
that's the power of hip-hop
hip-hop has always taken complex topics
and made them mainstream and cool
hip-hop has always influenced the
behavior of its listeners
hip-hop has always given voice to the
underrepresented
what if hip-hop took a complex topic
like climate change and made it
mainstream and cool
or if hip-hop influenced behavior that
protected our planet
or if hip-hop gave voice to the
environment or future generations who
can't speak for themselves
now using popular music to raise
awareness about climate change has
already started happening
two years ago the new york times
reported that there have been at least
192 references to climate change in any
song that has been made by any artist
who has been featured on any of
billboard's domestic charts over the
past few decades so not a lot
and i only need you a handful of the
songs
we need a lot more of that
but more importantly we need lyrics of
songs to transition from talking about
the problem
into the solution space i mean if you're
a rapper a songwriter a producer a
musician
we need you
we listen to you i bet most if not all
of you here have made a decision because
of music i certainly have i mean when i
was younger the first air force ones i
bought these are not air force ones but
the first air force ones i bought were
because of nelly song
now imagine if instead of rapping or
singing about maybachs or cadillacs the
most influential hip-hop artists in the
world made electric vehicles
aspirational
or instead of rapping about the bling
around their necks or in their mouths
they rapped about the solar panel bling
on their roofs
don't get me wrong the songs that i'm
referencing helped define my childhood
but what if my childhood was defined by
environmentalism
what if next year the grammy award for
best album or best song or best rap
album went to an artist to use their
platform to make one of the most
important topics of our generation
mainstream
to being climate to the culture
what if that got climate solutions to be
part of our vernacular
with that
create a movement
or raise the masses
or get people behind an idea to
inspire action
i think so
imagine the influence we can have
see we have this
incredible opportunity
to participate in the
biggest revolution we have ever seen
the revolution to secure a livable
future
and i believe that hip-hop
and culture are part of the solution
thank you
[Applause]